so after Donald Trump was reportedly talked
out of defending Matt Gates.
After Donald Trump reportedly rejected a meeting
with Matt Gates, Matt Gates spoke over the
weekend at some kind of very bizarre event
called the Save America Summit.
And despite Donald Trump having to be talked
out of defending Matt Gates, Matt Gates is
claiming that Donald Trump still supports
him.
Gates now believed to be the target of multiple
investigations, various different crimes,
including possibly child sex trafficking across
state borders.
Gates is saying, I have the support of Trump.
He also mentions he has the support of Jim
Jordan and Marjorie Taylor Green, two of the
most unhinged Republican members of Congress
right now.
Let's take a listen.
We have your back.
That is the sentiment I have heard from thousands
of Americans at restaurants walking through
public park, sometimes just out on the street
and emails, online donations.
And I can't tell you how much it means to
me.
This past week has been full of encouragement
from President Trump, Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Jim Jordan to the modern nation that shared
so much love.
So let me assure you, I have not yet begun
to fight for the country I love and for the
nation that I know benefits from America.
First principles.
I'm built for the battle and I'm not going
anywhere.
Matt Gates is talking like he's a victim here.
He's he's talking like he is the one that
everybody else is being unfair to.
He's making himself out to be almost like
a martyr of some kind over being investigated
for trafficking kids and paying for prostitutes.
And who knows what else.
It's becoming a horror movie and some total
then truly murdering himself, weirdly comparing
himself here to George H.W. Bush.
This is completely insane.
Listen to this clip.
Even suggesting that the deep state may be
after him.
When he accepted the 1988 nominee, Republican
nomination for President George Herbert Walker
Bush said, I'm a quiet man and I hear the
quiet people of our country will.
America first is not a quiet movement.
And I am not a quiet man.
I may be a canceled man in some corners.
I may even be a wanted man by the deep state.
But I hear the millions of Americans who feel
forgotten, canceled, ignored, marginalized
and targeted.
I draw confidence knowing the silent majority
is growing louder by the day in this great
country, and so I welcome to our movement,
the libertarians, the populists, the different
the cancel anyone who can rally around our
inclusive America first agenda.
What silent majority is Matt Gates talking
about?
A silent majority that supports child sex
trafficking.
Like what?
What is what is this guy on?
What planet is this guy on?
And it almost doesn't matter.
But just so that, you know, Matt Gates also
falsely claimed at this event that Trump won
the 2020 election.
So Gates is still doing all the same, sucking
up to Trump.
Trump seems to completely be rejecting Matt
Gates because Gates is not useful to him anymore,
saying he's a canceled man, you know, being
canceled and being held accountable for crimes
you may have committed.
Those are very, very, very different things.
And that is really some spin.
I mean, think about that.
We don't have millions of incarcerated criminals
in this country.
We have millions of canceled men in prison.
That's the new term for there are consequences
to your actions.
He's being investigated for paying kids maybe
four for maybe having paid kids for sex.
And he's framing himself as a hero because
law enforcement is investigating him.
It's almost more all right than it is Trump
in.
You know, Trump is known for skating by endless
allegations of all sorts.
His supporters don't idolize Trump for the
things Trump is accused of.
They either just don't believe the things
Trump is accused of or they ignore them and
say they don't matter.
Gates is almost going all right and that the
alt right actually will make heroes out of
people who did or are accused of having done
really horrible things.
So these are very strange times we live in.
And for me, the most important context is
it's April of twenty twenty one.
We're 19 months from the midterm elections.
What happens to the Republican Party in nineteen
months if this type of insanity continues?